match would be moving this quickly um so
big Cav out here modding I don't know
how to do this on my own I'm sorry if
you want another cell phone setup like
we did the last time we could do that
but anyway
India 32 left as long as they don't Wick
it the [__] out and they only got two
wickets although to be fair Pakistan was
at like 153 or whatever and two wickets
and then they completely collapse so as
long as India doesn't Pakistan it up we
should be fine we should be in the bag I
got my homie arjent Gupta coming over
he's on his way he actually knows
Cricket I'm the most casual I'll never
pretend I know Cricket like that oh Kev
um I'm going to ask you to set something
up for me bro no we got to give a shout
out to our boys at prize picks I need
that little banner up oh yeah do and we
need to put a little Link in the
description you know what I mean because
prize picks
they be hooking us up so if you that's a
little note just make sure that I wrote
down to make sure we we take care of
prize picks I didn't do prize picks for
this match um because I've been I've
I've been wrong every time quite frankly
but uh yeah we're going to we you know
prize picks covers Cricket I'm going be
honest I didn't even know they cover
Cricket they cover everything um so
shouts to them and uh they're the best
we're going to keep working with them Oh
I thought that was a
four yeah one maybe two out of that
we're setting up the IG live as well
guys cuz you know what I mean we need to
let people know to come
over I'm gon be honest I thought this
would be a much closer match I did not
think that Pakistan would would choke
the way they did so this is not going to
be the longest stream but you know we'll
have fun pakistanis are y'all in the
chat y'all got something to say were you
crying right now huh
I tried texting vaa guy gave me
nothing he just hit me with the emoji
with the swirly eyes that's all he had I
didn't really talk [__] though because I
was worried India would fall apart too
to be honest with you because I I hate
to jinx it with [__] talk um but again
if you know more than Cricket tell me
what's going on cuz it seems like this
is just a like barring a complete
collapse this is a blood bath you want
to see yourself in the live or no not at
all I guess I can see myself in the live
what's up oh this is Happy by the way
guys what's up guys we're live streaming
the World Cup of cricket it's brought to
you by Price picks oh you're going to
see me talking IG live don't think I
forgot about you YouTube what's up IG
live we're World streaming India versus
Pakistan World Cup of cricket we're kind
of beating that ass I'm gon be honest I
thought this would be a much longer
match and it might not be boring a
collapse which I guess Could Happen um
but anyway if you want to be a little
more interactive and whatnot you can go
to YouTube I'm streaming it we got a
banner hopefully with the score up I got
the priz P link prize picks link there
it's Akash by the way make your priz
picks um dude 130 only two wickets 19
overs the Run rate is actually even kind
of crazy we're at like a 6 point
something run rate right that's nuts
again I'm very casual as a cricket fan
but that seems higher than I expected I
usually see him like the fives never
above six you know anybody saying
anything funny on the YouTube chat big
Kev IG oh I can see the IG [__]
okay Pakistan is embarrassing y'all
right now I'm going to be honest I was
wild I only slept 3 hours cuz I can't
sleep and I plan on sleeping through
whoever batted first but uh I woke up
and I started watching the Pakistan
match and I was Pakistan the bats and I
was like look I don't know Cricket but
this seems very scary that they're at
like a 1 15 and they only got two
wickets and uh then they just fell the
[__] apart it was unbelievable I'd never
seen nothing like that let's go
four let's [__]
go uh Argent Gupta is coming again he
actually knows Cricket he's a very good
friend of mine he's an actor you might
have seen him on the show The Magicians
uh so his the plan was he should get
here at 10 but I did not think the match
would be over by 10:15 or whatever it's
going to be over by but we're going to
try to have fun regardless um if I had
Val if Val wasn't with Andrew he would
be streaming right now and then he would
be munching on Edibles like I was when
the Cowboys got washed by San Francisco
hey this is how you know God is real cuz
I'm a Cowboy fan I had to watch them get
destroyed by San Francisco just get butt
[__] by San Francisco and uh then God
gave me this you know what I mean that's
a six right there that's
crazy this guy Rohit shmer is I
mean I never seen this many sixes this
early again I'm very casual so correct
me if I'm wrong I never seen this many
sixes this early ever and I'm asking
you'all to correct me till Aran gets
here he'll no more but this is nuts
dude this like the sixth six maybe more
how many sixes he have Super Chat is it
called Super Chat yeah I don't know what
a Super Chat is I just started this live
streaming thing we're going to get into
that people pay someone said I show
speed is at the stadium for IND oh yeah
I show speed been this at the World Cup
of cricket this guy is oh that's y I
don't know him but he's a friend he's
a into the culture he's wearing the
India Jersey representing you know what
I mean oh arjent just texted me cuz he
didn't want me to sound like a [__] he
said talk about R shammer potentially
getting his 8th hundred in World Cups
that's crazy eight centuries in World
Cup would be wild uh he said that's he
thinks that's the most by any player
definitely the most by India yeah yo
he's at 80 I I mean guys we're 50 runs
off and we have eight wickets and 30
overs so again unless we just of
Pakistan here we're looking
okay by the way I don't again I watch I
really oh my God is that another
sixer That's crazy
dude oh that was shus okay um look if
you don't watch cricket you're missing
out frankly it's a great it's a great
game it's better than baseball I'm not
just saying that because I'm Indian uh
this is a real thing I realized uh the
tension playoff baseball is is fun cuz
there's like tension but the tension in
cricket is is each team bats once so
every single ball you're just getting
more and more tense and panicked and
like Pakistan is melting down right now
the way I was melting down in the first
half when they were batting and it just
keeps building and building and building
and it's just it's great dude it's great
I should watch more casually but I'm Pro
I mean I should watch more often but I'm
probably going to keep it casual happy
you want to get back in this come on
you're you're adding to the shot buddy
what's going on this is Happy guys this
this my pup my wife picked him out but I
love
[Music]
them
okay so we're at 149 two wickets we just
need 43 runs we got 29 overs left I mean
is anyone worried is anyone on YouTube
worried nobody
right look at Roi big chunky ass you
know what I love about Ro shmer he looks
like an uncle you know I mean this guy
is built like he my age maybe younger
but he built like when I was a kid
that's what uncles looked like just some
big Hindu Punjabi uncle just [__]
getting drunk on weekin
and yelling at kids cuz they're making
too much noise and he is just
demolishing the ball look at this that a
four oo that's a
four that's a four
right yeah
wait they're saying that's one that's
four right okay there it is scoreboard
scoreboard is
correcting yo if you want to look at
chat it's right there oh I could look at
chat too dude hey big Kev gave me his
phone that's why big Kev is the goat
sorry we couldn't be here earlier but
again I didn't uh think he I didn't want
to wake him up at 4:00
a.m. yo you know what's great though I I
live streamed uh NFL American football
and like 10 people are watching with me
live not 10 but not that many and then
in the chats were normally about non
sports stuff this is all look every
comment is about the actual
match chck there dog L speed why L speed
speed is rooting for
us all right I'm going to pay a little
attention I don't this looks like a four
that's a four oh never
mind yeah I played like uh cricket like
Speed play cricket with the like the
canvas not the canvas ball like the yeah
I guess the canvas like the green tennis
ball looking cricket ball and it was so
easy I was like this is the easiest game
I ever played in my life and then I
played once with a real ball and that
[__] hurt and the bat suddenly got wild
heavy and I just none of it I was not
into it I couldn't do it I always
thought I could be a pro a pro Cricket
player I could not I take it all
back but I do see why Indians excel at
it cuz you can look like R Sharma and be
one of the greatest tournament Players
ever you know what I mean you could look
like a Punjabi Uncle who eats three
patas put out every night before he goes
to bed and then you're still you know
what I mean
so oh somebody just asked when they see
me in Dubai hey
man I'm a little worried to go to that
whole region right now I'm going be
honest with you so I don't know maybe
when everything calms
down oh man v v power is very funny
oh it's all good dude I'm just looking
at these comments All right we
back man you know how was potentially
going to be at this match we couldn't
get Podcast stuff figured out in time
but I could have been there right now
but I I will say this if we can get
podcast schedule lined up I will be
there for I've never been to India for
thali so I want to go and if India is in
like I maybe it' be the semi-finals I I
will be at the match I promise you that
I will even go to gadr which I never
thought I would say dry ass State dry
ass people I kidding it's just a
anyway food is no good though I think we
can all say
that that's a nice sense ball right
there get a run off of
that can I ask everybody a question
about VI Ki I've never seen him play
well I don't again I watch World Cup
basically once in a while India Pakistan
I just don't ever see I don't see it
what am I
missing what am I missing but Rajan I
would love to go I didn't know y'all did
comedy like that but I would love to go
to ristan for for
comedy
someone said I'm copying speed by
watching Cricket yeah okay yeah the
Indian is the one copying sure
thing guys I watch this whole ass match
can you believe it I've been up since
4:30 maybe yeah I woke up I think I
might have missed the first couple of
overs maybe I don't remember uh but yeah
I was up watching on my phone and then I
moved to the room I was like what am I
doing o all right take a
run 36 runs from 28 overs is crazy it's
over guys I don't want to jinx it but
it's
over again the matches I've seen India
needs 36 runs from 28 balls not 28
overs yo you know what I will say about
K he got the craziest watch collection I
should actually be nice to that guy
figure out who his connect is because he
got every watch that you could ever
possibly
want oh there's a
wicked son of a [__]
dude charman didn't get his Century son
of a
[__] [__] as soon as I said it India is
going to lose actually I take it
back India's going to lose guys [__]
[__] they have the live odds on the
website it says that they're a 95.5%
chance to win so I think they still
might be good I know but that just s
dude that guy was sh was playing
incredibly he was the one getting all
the runs really Tre is playing fine but
I think I mean we're still looking good
but [__] that
hurts 100 he was 14 runs off of 100 too
a centur is a big it's like a big big
deal you doesn't go again you're out
you're done you're out of the match I
mean you don't bat again yeah either 10
wickets or 50 overs and each over is six
balls so 300 balls or 10
wickets and then I didn't realize this
Argent explained this to me wickets I
think I said this to you earlier wickets
can come in bunches because it takes a
batter a while to like get set get
comfortable and he was in a Groove This
Guy's in a groove by now but then
there's another one coming up so
this is
theu when is flavr coming to India
someone said bro realize nuz it real
time that's funny I did dude I put nuz
it on them uh when am I come to India
dude I'll be there hopefully in no
November for the and then maybe we'll do
like a popup show or something like that
I haven't done a proper tour yet um
because I'm afraid you're going to throw
me in jail but uh yeah we're we're going
to try to organize that I just need some
kind of immunity diplomatic
immunity all right I don't know is this
guy Rao good you guys tell me I don't
know
so anybody is this guy good I'm waiting
on the chat
here no all right all right guys fair
enough all right by the way you're
tuning in this is brought by Price picks
um I didn't know they even did Cricket
dude these guys cover everything you
just pick more or less on anything you
want to how many runs who gets most
sixes if you're watching uh soccer they
got cck NHL NFL whatever League you want
to do they got it and um they'll take
care of you so sign up with prize picks
use the promo code aash and they'll
match your initial deposit up to $100
that's $1 free dollars that just gave
you you're
welcome yo Happy is so mad at me about
this putting the nuz on road road shmer
he just left my lap do you notice that
has nothing to do with me this kid other
end of the
couch all right I'm still feeling okay
35 runs 28
overs this is this is
doable
R used to open up the Innings okay I
it's not Raul I think it's rul I'm
pretty sure right that'd be weird um but
okay that's comforting to know he used
to open it
up someone said Schultz is jut that's so
funny he is so
jut yeah somebody just asked me how much
it cost to do dental procedures in the
US what a weird [__] question that is
man I I don't
know okay no one's nervous right is
anyone nervous at all
anybody I'm a little nervous to be
honest with
you there you go just don't don't go for
too much just take it easy one Run's
fine you don't even need to run half the
time you would even need to run on half
of these balls you can still win so
let's just
all chill you know what I mean oh arent
said kale is a beast so he
knows I'm nervous breath because I don't
know anything about Cricket jackass
that's why I'm nervous I don't know
nothing you know what I don't like is
seeing how many people are in the corner
watching that that [__] bugs me out I
don't want to see if the number dropped
you know what I
mean YouTube I can see that
too
hey hey Kev Kev did a nice little job on
the YouTube page you got the the score
running we can't do the match because
you know Disney Disney Plus or whatever
I'm watching on ESPN plus but um NFL
games we it's stream picture and picture
so you can watch with us you can watch
the Cowboys disappoint me incessantly
whenever you want to uh all right we're
good 158 22 I don't even know what to
talk about with you guys I thought let
me tell you guys something we're going
to keep streaming cricket matches and
the close ones are going to be riveting
if you watch along with me I'm serious
I'm not bullshitting you it's pick a
side that you want to win that's the
only way it's going to be truly fun and
it will be
riveting maybe the best sport to
watch yeah yeah if on with these Stakes
yeah look at that
dude
look at Uncle G Ro Sharma
dude a great
shck see I didn't even notice but let's
start putting that in the standup
specials Kev said they there very
cinematic uh it's a great cinematography
in
these y again I don't know Cricket but
you know who the swaggiest player is
arjent you tell me what you think Bunda
hardic Bunda crazy Swagger dude guys
whole the whole steas I just love
it showing Sydney soon we're going to
work on that we're going to work on it
roro we're going to work on it thanks
for the the $3 Australian that's
probably like 60 cents American right I
appreciate it though I
do oh that was you actually that's you I
appreciate
it Kev just signed in on the laptop of
laptop all right guys let's go let's
let's let's see what they're saying
here Sharma demolished Afghanistan last
last match um it's Afghanistan right
it's not Afghanistan it's Afghanistan I
said that and Schultz yelled at me like
an [__] but I'm pretty sure Afghani
say it Afghanistan anyway that's
all finally a white man introduced
Cricket to an Indian I don't know Joe
Rogan you think Joe Rogan told me about
let me tell you my first experience
watching cricket was the World Cup
2009 or
[Music]
2011 whenever India won I don't remember
what year it was because I'm getting old
but I went to Murray Hill in in the like
the Indian part of Manhattan where all
the Indian restaurants are and I watched
at a bar and it was the craziest most
fun experience ever they beat Sri Lanka
in the final and that's when I was
saying everybody started
chanting
Pakistan and we were playing Sri Lanka
like I said so it was really funny that
we were still chanting that but it was
just it was so fire dude so ever since
then World Cup of cricket I'm tuning in
I can't do non National stuff I can't I
just I don't have the time or
whatever the word is I don't care enough
uh but World Cup I'm always tune in
that's going to happen for
sure dude y'all keep asking for shows in
India can I can you ask the government
to not put comics in jail then maybe I'm
GNA be there safely I'm not even making
a stand I'm just
scared 2011 deep thank
you Bund drops the nword he got the pass
that's I you know what look him up yeah
I think
so all right
162 we're good
dude I'm sorry this match isn't closer
to be honest with
you kind be honest with you a lot of
yall are asking for jobs and whatever I
just saw another one here's what I
noticed every time I give an Indian an
opportunity he just doesn't do [__] cuz
he knows he can get away with more with
me and then eventually I have to I have
to let go of them and so it's really
hard for me to find Indians that don't
take advantage of the fact that they
know I'm going
to be racist in their favor really it's
become an unfortunate
truth it's
crazy I had a guy show up three hours
late to pick me up one time cuz he had a
car and he was supposed to take me to a
show 3 hours late I had to rent my my
own car I got there 10 minutes late
because he overslept I asked him picked
me up at 2:
p.m. that's what happens when you work
with brown people and you're Brown and
they know that they love that you're
Brown [__] take
advantage the score is not
updating it's not that far off dude it's
it's eight runs off it's 162 that's
not oh yeah no it's two it's two overs
behind all all
right guys I wish Argent got here a
little bit earlier I uh really I was
trying to be nice you know but I don't
know what the [__] else to talk about
this match is so much in the bag what
are we going to even do you
know we're going to keep doing this
though when is India's next match like I
said I'm a casual I don't know but I'm
we're going to stream it not I know 4:00
a.m. I
can't you know had big
Kev plotting in here at 400 a.m. waking
up my wife you know but we're going to
stream the next match at a reasonable
hour I'll tell you that
much couple people ask me to speak Hindi
I would but all y'all do is criticize
our accent and then you give us a
complex because I can speak Hindi well
enough not incredibly well but well
enough and uh
then my Indian family always makes fun
of me like their English sounds normal I
just let that [__] slide for 39 years
like they're not like totally you know
what I
mean be infuriating
me oh Kev you you're getting I think
texts and I think I'm getting them I
keep looking at your
phone um I don't think so my okay Bet
she texted me 10 minutes ago oh maybe
that's what I
saw Akash how's your relationship with
Akash Gupta I don't know him to be
honest with you Akash do a flip do I
look like a [__] trained monkey to
you what the [__] kind of [__] is that
do a flip do a flip are you out of your
[__] mind bro first of all I can't do
a flip can you who could do a flip in
the chat if you could do a flip let me
know in the chat and then text me a
[__] video or DM me a video cuz
I still don't believe you do a flip what
the [__] is that I'm on a black couch
watching Cricket at 10:00 a.m. you
telling me do a
flip I'm not a circus animal I love I
love the super
da I love occasionally hearing that and
I think it's only shre is doing it but
it makes me so happy I just love
it it's like
carel [__] out yes but it's so it's so
DIY it's just you wear gloves not not
when you field you don't wear gloves
when you field only the batter wears
gloves because that [__] is that ball is
dense dude there's a lot of shock when
it hits and put a lot of Spin and
whatever on Pace on
it I do think I'd be a nice Fielder you
put
me back I think I'd be
nice like right there I got that bang if
it's in the air light work catch every
time wicked
wicked batting I don't know I might I
you know you might might be more
Pakistani than Indian when it comes to
batting wait hold
on we went to Staley middle school so
hey hey this is great I want to clip
this moment a ab ab Ren designs we went
to stale Middle School in Frisco
together and I just want to say to you
no we didn't you got me confused with
another Brown guy cuz I didn't go to
Frisco until I was 17 years old so I
just want you to sit in that everybody
commented him Arin is here let me go
open the
door
and then we can probably move the cam to
see what's up how you doing good man how
are you this is miked up yeah you got
hey guys this is arjent oh this this is
arjent he's sitting in this is my
brother and he he actually knows cricket
oh hi right now it's just happy
actually grab a seat buddy there a live
stream of happy taken over me hi
sweetheart hi Hi
O look at this hand son of a [__]
huh voice you know we're here dude we
there this match is going to be over in
15 minutes I mean I told you I told you
starting at 10 was foolish you missed
the whole thing Roi went crazy well I
just I told him but why were you getting
nervous tell me that because you said
wickets happen in bunches yeah but not
when you're chasing 20 not when you're
chasing 19 dud I don't know these things
you know what I mean I don't know these
things this is
crazy yeah now you said do you remember
you said like a month ago India doesn't
look good they're probably not going to
do well I might have you also talked me
how of going to this match I I did talk
you had to go to this match why you
don't I didn't think that first of all
you said it wouldn't be fun cuz it's all
Indian and it's fun when it's half
Indian it would be more fun that way for
sure that would be yeah sure but also
like I also was reading that was just
like a complete am I the only one on are
they not we're moving this one back okay
cuz I was going to say like this is just
all of a sudden no one wants to see me
right now all all them want to see you
no no no son son we're still doing fine
no you can just move the
phone move the chair there you go there
we go there's that pretty guy I think
that I think the chair broke did it yeah
let's get both of us in this shop though
there you
go all
right hey hey let's just sit man close
together you know what's camera um I can
flip the camera but here's the thing
that's honestly crazy about this though
yeah Pakistan is straight up went into
the Asia cup which happened a few weeks
ago right before this as the number one
team in ODI it's like straight up the
best team can I be honest with you you
said ODI and I don't know what that
means one day international a 50 over
this is why okay there you go see guy
knows things man tell me that's not an
expert tell me that's not an expert dude
just the so it's T20 and ODI and test
and test is test is the five day the two
innings we don't who does that in I I
will wake up at 3:00 in the morning for
a test still play love test matches it's
actually my favorite format to watch
this is great I mean I love it T20 is
more fun than I thought it would be T20
is more fun because like it's explosive
it's just fireworks all the time but if
you if like if you like the chess match
of it the setting up if you like
watching and ushn does this beautifully
cuz he'll like set you up he'll do three
balls in a certain way it's like people
that love a pitching battle you know
what I mean RI Chandra Ashwin he's all
right he's uh a finger spinner this is J
Shaw he's the
BCCI secretary
you would think that he would not have
all the power because he's the secretary
but he really runs the show the whole
show well dude I like what he's doing
right now I do I'm a fan how could he
not be you know
um so but yeah Pakistan so win into Asia
cup as like the
but you got to wonder what like they
just can't there there this is going to
be their eth loss to India in World Cup
history like they've never beaten India
in the World Cup really never never
they're own they're 0 for seven I think
in od yeah T20 I think they H have they
actually I don't know about that but I
know that in this that was the big
stat that everyone was talking about
before this
match and who was favored coming in
there wasn't it was hard to there was
hard to say
that I mean Pakistan's played really
well in the last two
matches the only issue is
okay now I'm going to get real like
nerdy on you they're they are a little
bit outdated in the way they play in
that their majority of their runs comes
from their top four players mhm what's
happened and and I hate to credit
England because I just don't like to do
that but England changed the way the
game was played because they just they
go hard and they bat deep they bat
through 10 yeah it feels like the way
you should do it but no because used to
be like your specialist your Bowlers
would be the ones at the end right so
why would your Bowlers be practicing how
to bat it's like expecting it's
expecting a pitcher to like be
your yes it's expecting a lot of that
which is just it's hard to do that it's
just like not everyone has those skills
so but England has changed the game
where you bat deep now now not everyone
bats that deep right but but
India bats deep through eight they want
to have eight eight players that can
that can score runs see I was
never in the last like 15 years it's
been really hard to be confident when
like when Coy would go out it was like
duler back in the day like when duler
went out you're like [__] we're [__]
right Coy went out I remember you I I
used to feel similarly but now like I
feel so confident I never watched an
Indian team where I felt as confident
about one side as the other side it used
to be I would feel confident about the
batting side but not the bowling side
sorry doesn't Ro tra looks like look
like an uncle just a
complete drunk at
parties man you have you you got to
watch this do in a press conference he
is the most Charming he is so funny he
is such a Bombay guy I love this dude AR
lives in India and America by the way I
mean I don't know if I'd say I live in
India can he just do the thing I'll do
the thing I live yaret the truth a
little bit can we not have some
emotional troops out
what's going on dude just you know we're
doing oural
P you
know oh but you do go to India for
months at a time no I do I do no for
sure I mean and his wife is proper
Indian yeah my wife is proper she's the
real deal wait is she NRI now I never
know what NRI NRI is a non-resident
India yeah I thought NRI was us but but
anyone that moves to I think become I
think if you I wow that's interesting I
didn't I always thought my mom was
Indian and I'm an NRI but right right
right she's also an NRI but she's but
she's got the Indian citizenship does
your mom actually still I don't think
she does she's been here for 50 years
now my Dad held onto his green card for
a long time oh really mhm my mom moved
here when she was 14 so I don't even
know if those decisions were like or at
least list right fair I don't even know
this I these orange is G this is such a
BJP thing it's so irritating but the
Jersey Flames dude huh the Jersey Flames
the blue yeah yeah yeah of course it
looks better to me they modify it at all
cuz I tried buying one maybe I bought a
fake one uh like 2015 and it was it is
crazy difficult to find Cricket merchand
like I it's why don't the the whole
infrastructure they don't have fan shops
yeah there's like why isn't there like
it should be so simple for me to be buy
a Jersey it's so annoying I've wanted to
buy a jersey many times you can't do it
on Nike no I remember once like back in
' 05 I had I had a cricket Jersey and I
customized it to put my name on this was
back when I had long hair I went to the
IND Day parade and made fun of me they
were like yo dony dony and at that time
I got to be honest I wasn't F Cricket as
much so I didn't really know what the
[__] they were talking about I like why
are you making what is this yeah I look
but
um they don't actually look good when
you're like wearing them with jeans like
walking around though like on a dayto
day sh you haven't met sh be works on on
the Pod he was wearing one and I I
thought it looked great and that's why I
was like oh they must have modified it
some or he just found a legit one all um
but so my first I was s tell them my
first experience watching Cricket like
live as it's happening was 2011 when
they won the World Cup oh wow and suchin
was that was his last World Cup and then
everybody's doing the such and such and
then he got out pretty quickly and then
dony had I think he had Sentry and he
went crazy and then the chance morphed
as India started to win to Don Don and
it was just so [__] hold so great but
then after that I was like why I don't
want to watch non-h high stakes Cricket
I just watch the most high stakes so now
everything else is like all right me
yeah but that's it's there it's I love
the game truly I do love that you don't
need
to be physically
athletic I do I disagree with that gives
me hope that you cuz I'm I'm very
coordinated but I I can't I can't build
a muscle to save my life it is it is a
skill it is a skill game yeah it's much
more of a skill game now you need power
and all of that but you don't actually I
mean the power the power comes so much
like if you look at shman Gill I mean
you look at Roy sha I mean Roy sh is not
like bench pressing two or 25 he look he
looks like the the fat strong guy but
okay but shman gill who was the first
guy the guy right here on the left right
that guy looks thin you know the power
comes from timing the power comes from
actually cuz I used to when I was
playing I used to get in the that it's
like with tennis almost you know like
tennis if you try to hit too hard you're
not going to it's it's like that marage
of effort and ease take over yeah yeah
yeah and so it's these guys are like I
mean sure they're all athletic now
they're all really fit Fitness has
become a huge thing you know as you can
see the the body of a an Indian
cricketer has changed dramatically in
the last 15 years and that's a lot I
mean in the last 10 years that's a lot
Co oh yeah yeah yeah
and it's help man their Fielding is you
know yeah they're not the best Bowlers
who is not India oh they I think they
have the best bowling unit for sure I do
in this for the World Cup for This World
Cup being because so who's on paper
better than them
it's look at this that's just that's
just timing I mean that's just like he
just punched at that ball he didn't hit
it he's
not okay okay so here's what I cuz I
played one time for real I played with
like the canvas or the tennis ball or
what that was nothing that's light work
then I played with a real ball one time
and I don't think I had on pads but I
was like this [__] hurts it sucks I
don't want to do it it's heavy but I do
think if I played I grew up in India I
think I'd be nice at Cricket I think you
would be too because you do have good
hand ey coordination [__] y'all I mean
judging me you don't know my
life and you know what actually being
short helps you in this really this game
is built for Indians dude the English
didn't know what they did fuing idiots
[__] dumb asses stupid
[__] um they gave us tea and Cricket
what a bunch of retards didn't they also
like they mean they took the claim to
have invented soccer also yeah but we're
not good at that I'm just saying no but
short it's again another sport where
it's you know the shorter you are like
tends to help you uh lower lower center
of gravity yeah I guess so yeah yeah
yeah there not a ton of really really
tall soccer football play look at these
guys dude that's a lot are the guys that
get like face painted I don't understand
face painting at any that wasn't face
paint I know I know but that's just like
a lot yeah I don't know worst one rally
after this one worst purchases I ever
made I got really caught up I got went
and got a a Naro type jacket and I got
white and I got the piping to be the
tricolor and that sounds fire it's not
it sound fire to be honest really cuz
you're so damn tacky I assume that you
would have loved that [__] I assume that
you would have been like yo give me one
of those D I'm 39 now I've grown mean
I'm a mature man I dress like an adult
sometimes not now not in my home in my
office but you know I have an office you
have an office that's grownup type [__]
you have an office oh yeah let's see
what the chat is talking about this is
just people saying coms I looked at it
oh yeah that's
right um score got stuck on the screen
you people are very upset about this
score not updating we need 16 runs from
132 balls guys don't worry about the
score BR arent getting marriage
proposals in here there's a lot of
people talking about how hot you are oh
here we go is arjent married I have a
cousin who's a doctor he is married I'm
married and yeah but I get it and I
hated on it before cuz I I think I
didn't I didn't also realize how much
women liked tall which probably helped
me in my life cuz if I knew it would
have really dramatically impacted my
confidence uh but he's got the voice
he's tall he's yeah I get it I I get it
but he's married happily very happily so
back off
hoose but it wasn't actually you know
what's interesting that proposal wasn't
it was for that person's cousin yeah
sure there's more I know but I'm just
saying it's funny I was like do you want
to ask that person are they
interested son I have a feeling it's a
woman who's hitting 30 and they're
interested oh my God see this this
feels this is what's s because look I
genuinely wanted a competitive match I'm
going to be honest for for the stream I
do wish it was more competitive so they
could see that it's fun straight up I I
wanted a more competitive match because
India Pakistan deserves like a rivalry
game it's see this is the thing about it
it's not Australia like I was thinking
about this when on the when I was in the
cab over I was like would I feel I don't
feel like excited that we're B like
we're we're destroying them right now
yeah if we were destroying Australia I
would be so happy if we were destroying
England I would be so happy the reason
is because Pakistan hasn't been winning
that much lately you know what I mean I
mean so yes we have a rivalry that I
feel like is is somewhat more
geopolitical than anything else right
but from a standpoint of like an actual
cricketing thing like
it we don't play each other enough so
that that is fire though that I would
be the blue with but it's like a fat
suit I know it's like a it's that's fire
that's the way to do it I mean that is I
me but there's the spirit of it for sure
someone said tea and Cricket is better
thaned in football yo a decent that is a
good ass Point AR makes great Shai I
don't I do ladies back
off I made it because of my wife
actually because I didn't know I was
like how do I keep this around leaves
right yeah yeah God bless I mean my
wife's from as Sam so like she brings it
her uncle's play like she brings it from
maacha they had the best chai out there
right I think it's just like some people
love darelene she loves asames too okay
okay okay I don't like I don't even man
you know my parents did lipin mhm of
course and my mom would just do Straight
milk toward the end she was like don't
even [__] with water put straight milk
in a microwave wow and then I just throw
a teabag in there so I didn't know
people were so particular about their
chai I was like well yeah this and it
was great to me to be honest you throw a
little sugar in there you're partying
what's the problem no I mean yeah I mean
everyone does their chai differently and
that's the the beauty of it but yeah I
didn't know people were like like
particular about it oh yeah yeah now I
mean as I got older everyone's like but
growing up 13 14 she be like hey can you
make me chy so I was just like really
distracted by like I don't understand
people that do the dips the polar dips
oh you're not an ice bath guy I feel
like you would be an ice bath
guy I feel like you would love ice baths
if you started doing it like on a on
like a regular B I've been at a spa
where I've done like a a sauna and then
jumped into a cold plunge for like yeah
I feel like you would love that I guess
that's the same thing isn't it yeah I
think you it's like really right up your
alley you're like a big health and
fitness guy yeah I'm a big health and
fitness but there's the there's also
such a myth around how cold what is that
cold plunging is the the new trend it's
it's a new trend it's like I it's
[__] yeah I've heard it's basically
good for proving to your mind that you
can endure hard things that's really the
benefit great do hard things yeah yeah
yeah I [__] I love people but wait I
really want to go back to because this
he I think it was if thear had the ball
and it rolled under him and then it went
for a boundary there was on the way over
here there was um another boundary Guy
where like it went to him and this is
just this is it's over it's over was it
chat the [__] out of me oh you like
fully sprled out he's sleeping dude this
dog
sleeps super high energy and then he
naps hard
that's the way life should he walked
five miles yesterday this Maniac two and
a half hours I was walking it's crazy he
just wanted to get you fit yeah he he'll
just he was like you getting sloppy dog
yeah thank thank
God the question is do you think he
tries to go for a six to end it you have
to I mean why not you got 123 balls to
spare like let's just so let me ask you
this yeah is it like a fatigue a thing
at all with batting or would they like
put the guys at the end of the order who
didn't get to bat they push them up no
no they wouldn't do that in baseball but
I would just they would sometimes switch
like let's say for example and you're
not going to understand any of the
context I'm about to say but there's uh
sometimes for left- hand rightand
combinations sometimes we'll do that
that you'll understand because I'll do
that in baseball that that makes sense
but like sometimes match situation if
you have less overs left and you let's
say you're batting first and you want to
get a bigger score you might throw in
someone who's a bit more of a a finisher
someone who can like kind of is a little
bit more accelerating there's some
people that take time like KL likes to
take a few a little bit slower right
okay Rohit likes to just start yeah
Surya Kumar who's who's one of the most
exciting players in cricket who I'm like
really hope gets a gets some matches
here this cup um I mean he just goes
from the beginning you watch him in T20
it's it is pure entertainment He is
unbelievable Australia sucks This World
Cup right now which is amazing I'm so
happy who's good England England's not
been playing Super well which is
confusing South
Africa's look so good New Zealand is
amazing we
look frankly complete we look complete
oh going back to like bowling un you
asked that who's better on paper for
Indian conditions because Indian
conditions can change so much meaning
that you need really there's been
there's tracks where you need really
good Spinners and then there are tracks
where you need Pace good
Pace I just feel like we have the
complete we have any you whatever pitch
we're on we can put together a team
that's going to be really solid for that
pitch whereas Australia doesn't have
strong Spinners right their their Pace
attack is I mean not as much this world
cup but traditionally and those players
are very very strong but you know on a
turning pitch how does that help you you
know South Africa I haven't been
following the last eight months because
they South Africa don't deserve nothing
they were they what is they were they
just gave black people rights like 30
years ago what are we even talking
about yeah so we're going to start
judging whether people should we we're
going to start doing that cuz that
becomes really complicated no India is
good to everybody
dude to everyone dude oh man we love all
people
yeah traditionally we do like actually
in our our spirit we do there you go
let's go what's the chat what people
want to know the dog is tired as [__]
I'm leaving hey cashlin hey cashlin I
didn't think you were staying to be
honest with
you cashlin what a name I be honest
seeing it without the screen why if you
get sling you might be a why why we
should look into sling CU Disney it's
the ESPN plus I'm watching on and Disney
is a little more protective
about what gets to play where so if we
do NFL YouTube or YouTube TV owns the
NFL Sunday Ticket so it's no issue right
sling might be tough but we can try with
for sling we'll do we'll do a test run
streaming the next cricket match when is
India's next cricket match you would
probably know this 19th when is the n
it's done there we go baby oh and he got
a 50 with it
beautiful did he I think so hey
guys Pakistani I'm sorry this went so
poorly for you uh I don't even want to
rub it in cuz y'all got beaten so badly
they finish anything oh it's over it's
over dog India won God y'all are losers
huh it's unbelievable [__] you got
destroyed you had 155 runs with two
wickets y yeah I know that's that was a
pretty it's un score predictor were
saying
300 they got 190 they
190 and then we did we even get halfway
through our overs that's a good question
I was wondering how many I think we did
I think we had 26 overs guys this is way
quicker than I thought it would be again
I apologize we're going to do this again
and it'll be higher stakes and if India
goes to the finals you want to go to
India I think I will be India o I'm
going for the Walia hopefully if we can
get Podcast St sorted so if you're in
India we're going yeah I think we're
going towards the end of November maybe
yeah we can PR you're in Indie and I'm
in Indie we should just go I don't know
tickets are probably expensive but for
them with their with their Exchange
you know I mean [__] unbelievable
what you
guys oh man India genuinely looks so
strong 100 rupees in America won't even
get you a stamp ain't that crazy what
are you talking about that's not even
not exactly accurate but it's say it
depicts it depicts how devalued money is
rupes ain't getting you a stamp I think
it does how much is a stamp stamp's 37
cents no it's like 50 they're high now
they're 50 CS yeah now who's the idiot
yeah I I know I was like wait a minute I
don't know how much a Stam cost don't
you have those forever who doesn't buy
forever stamps stamps are 66 cents 66
cents so 100 rupees you cutting it close
no you're not I'm cutting it close it's
like 80 right now right it is 80 yes so
definitionally box on in their muds in
the mud just like their War history bro
it's all sold out I know bro we're going
to buy resale but you you think I'm
getting R we're just going to get in we
got guys in India you just got to have a
guy you have a guy we'll have a guy
we'll find a guy I think I might have a
guy I we I we had four tickets if we
wanted for this oh yeah yeah who you
were going to take the pot out there no
but with I want to get as many tiet I
need to take big Kev out there can you
imagine this big [__] in India I
want to get big Kev to film me and then
another guy to film big Kev I know it's
going to be amazing and just the
reaction just the reaction of people
just staring 611 611 white guy people
just staring in a sea of five8
Indians just sea of it dude that's my
favorite thing about Indians I'm not
short over there I know I'm fine no I
mean like if I'm like 510 you feel like
you belong there man I do I know I feel
that way too yeah but you're 6'2 so
you're like or whatever 6'1 yeah so
they're like you're tall me they just
don't think anything of it nobody thinks
you're short they're like that's just a
guy that's another one that's pretty
great
all right guys thank y'all for watching
you can sign off if you want to if not I
I owe this guy some something because he
came over here for 20 minutes of cricket
20 minutes of completely anticlimactic
Cricket oh yeah but that's blame
Pakistan for that that's that's y'all's
fault the partition is y'all's fault um
my Kashmir is y'all's fault and this
match and him his cab fair so just add
that to the T you go you owe this guy
you owe you owe India uh Kashmir and
argent's tab Fair cab Fair that's what
you owe
him so you know be think about
that drop some money in the chat for
this guy or something you
know yeah I'm sure I added such a value
you did dude I didn't know what the [__]
was going on was going man talking out
of my ass be honest this dude texted me
in the morning yeah he texted me and he
goes I'm not going to say it it's all I
asked how many wickets there were yeah I
thought there was 10 but it was like I
got confused but anyway I knew but I
just got confused because I was like
they can't be gone this quickly that's
Pakistan's fault too that's also a yell
you think about it such a good team man
so likable too top to bottom everyone's
really
likable yeah that really matters to you
it does matter to me it does matter to
me like shockingly little I disappoints
me how little it matters to me what is
that R is so
funny he's such like a
that is what you I know what you mean
though because like he doesn't look like
he tries that hard he's it's so
effortless and he's just like it feels
like he's just hanging out and he has a
pit dude and he has a pit absolutely all
of these things make him so likable like
Coy like it's you feel like him grinding
like it's effort like and you I admire
his resilience his grit his his his
intelligent cuz he's a grinder
right but roit is like he's out like
just having fun he yeah I mean your
drunk uncle thing was pretty drunk uncle
telling
you he's the guy at the party that's got
the like the beer on his head or
whatever and he's doing the Bund he's
doing all of that yeah for sure this is
uh J bura yeah yeah yeah and he had two
wickets yeah but and then he also caught
one yeah yeah for sure fielded one how
you you he caught you just catch the
ball dude KN that but can I say this
that was we but did you notice hard hard
like you just swagy as [__] that guy
yeah he is Swaggy know for sure for sure
but like the the ease that he had that
you could you watching a wicket a big
Wicket and you're able to like mock the
dude for the way he caught it he's
making fun of the dude for the way
Boomer caught it and I'm like you're so
chill right now you're not celebrating
the fact that you got a wicket you're
making fun of how you got the Wicket oh
the the last match I watched was India
Pakistan in India last September I think
it was T20 oh that match was that match
was when they won on the last ball that
was one of the greatest matches one of
the greatest matches of cricket I've
ever seen it was incredible Co Coy was
but he he bowled out in that match too
he he is he no Bunda mad sixes I
remember oh yeah and it was crazy me
it's such a small guy knocking the [__]
out of the ball oh yeah yeah yeah him
and him and
um and then there was that other Punjabi
uh bowler that was good I don't know
what happened to him young looking guy
skinny EP I think deep yeah yeah I think
what happened to him he didn't make it
no they have stronger they have stronger
stronger fast Bowers
damn this guy I love this guy he just
looks cute he's adorable he's adorable
this is adorable yeah he looks like he
tries
hard
be honest sometimes I get disappointed
when they speak in English why you know
this is why I say I have such a complex
about my Hindi accent cuz he's [__]
yeah I mean I do too and then I every
time I want to be like I'm sorry what do
you think your English sounds like I get
so Ang not every time it built up over
years and now I'm just I'm completely
okay I'm totally okay making fun of
their stupid accents oh my cuz they make
fun of my stupid accent yeah we're even
we both sound idiotic and the other
person's native
tongue all right I think we're good guys
look hey you want to come for the next
match at a more reasonable hour I mean
earlier yeah I mean you got to start for
the power play dog yeah what time is
okay but this is okay so like 8:30 a.m.
on the night what day of the week is
that 19th was a Thursday I got that
that's great let's do it yeah Thursday
morning I'm free I believe you should
check who they're playing
though who are they playing Kev can you
look this up chat I got to ask you but I
don't know kev's is anyone still on the
chat are there people still here of
course there's so people dude we're
talking yeah we dude come on people are
hanging out we're all hanging out we're
just having a good
time having a gay old time with The
Flintstones starts at 4:30 a.m. they're
playing
Bangladesh we're GNA [__] them up right
yeah man doesn't I mean and then Sunday
the 22nd they play New Zealand at 4:30
oo wait Sunday Sunday the 22nd if I'm
here we'll do that New Zealand yo that
would be a good game those guys are
scary
all right so you could do Bangladesh too
if you want to come over yeah we we'll
see all right you know but New Zealand
if I'm in town we might be out of town
but if I'm in town let's do it let's do
it next Sunday next Sunday morning oh
yeah you be going somewhere no I should
be back by Sunday I guess right because
we're going to stream NFL yeah yeah and
then Monday night is a Cowboys game this
week this week Monday night Monday night
we're streaming Cowboys Chargers and you
can watch the game picture and picture
because YouTube TV ain't [__] around
we're going to try to figure out this
sling thing too we'll do some Drive runs
thank you guys so much for watching Love
yall thanks jind V
mam Pakistan